the large arctic air mass is pushing
across the country keeping hundreds of
millions of americans in the deep freeze
this weekend
snow started falling in seattle friday
and there could be up to a half a foot
of accumulation by the time it's over
passing the city's average annual
snowfall in less than a day
it's part of a nationwide polar plunge
with snow ice and cold temperatures
expected
in nearly every corner of the country
charlie demar begins our coverage
in chicago charlie good morning
jeff good morning from a frozen over
chicago as you can see the snow
already coming down you can't even make
it out but behind me lake michigan also
covered in snow
and icy on top of these below freezing
temperatures it's this brutal cold
that is making it just unbearable for so
much of the country and for parts of the
country
that aren't used to seeing these
conditions well they'll be getting a
taste this weekend
get ready for america's roadways to look
a lot like this
this weekend a coast to coast storm is
howling across the country
with nearly half of all americans in its
path this
is a historic cold spell
that has the potential of causing
tremendous disruption to our region
in texas they're treating this arctic
blast and incoming storm with the same
seriousness
as a hurricane and for good reason an
ice storm earlier in the week caused
this 130 vehicle pileup which killed at
least six people
across the plains temperatures are below
zero and that's before you factor in the
wind chill
it can feel as cold as 30 to 40 below
when the winds start to blow
drivers and usually rainy seattle are
getting a grip on how to handle snow
while flyers are simply trying to get
away largo florida
you know why tell me because it's 81
degrees there
not here plow trucks at seattle tacoma
airport ready to roll
we have more than 45 pieces of equipment
for snow and ice maintenance we have
like
thousands of gallons of anti-ice fluid
and i literally mean tons of sand when i
say tons of sand
while plow trucks are revving up
delivery drivers are planning on playing
it
safe as they drop off valentine's day
flowers in the midst of this wintry
weather
we prepare them ahead of time we're like
okay this road starts to get slick you
know pull over
now along with texas oklahoma and
louisiana all declaring states of
emergency for this winter weather
less than ideal conditions for mardi
gras data
charlie thank you a plus effort in
articulating in that cold weather go get
warm